autre élection cette fois au kosovo avec
des législatives anticipées
un scrutin qui pourrait marquer un
tournant historique avec une probable
victoire d'un tout jeune parti le
vetëvendosje les traductions
autodétermination cette formation de
gauche nationaliste et pourrait
l'emporter grâce notamment au vote de la
jeunesse une nouvelle génération a
excédé par la corruption qui ronge le
territoire depuis l'auto proclamation de
son indépendance en 2008 et une très
forte pauvreté aggravée par la crise
sanitaire à plus de 100 milles kosovar
de l'étranger se sont par ailleurs
inscrits pour voter par correspondance
et en direct dans ce gîte et alexis
trousset chercheur en histoire et en
géopolitique spécialiste des balkans
auteur entre autres de ouvrage balkans
la fracture la base européenne du djihad
aux éditions xenia
bonjour alexis trou de merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin en direct sur
arte france la jeunesse avide de
changement d'un côté les ex commandant
de l'ofce cas de l'autre est ce que ces
législatives se résume à ce bref
raccourcis ou bien ce que c'est plus
compliqué que ça acolyte un peu plus
compliqué que ça le contexte pour le
kosovo est assez étonnant et détonnant
douze ans après l'autoproclamation
l'indépendance les spectateurs se
souviennent que cette indépendance a été
proclamée par en fait une fraction
minime à des albanais du kosovo qui
étaient les anciens le commandant du
check a alors depuis et il a eu
énormément de gens de le pied cas qui
ont été jugés et qui ont maintenant jugé
par un tribunal spécial pour tous comme
o2 est un facteur il ya aussi les la
question de la reconnaissance elle même
cet état qui est de moins en moins
reconnu c'est un fait historique de 4 ou
5 ans beaucoup de pays sont revenus en
arrière
il ne considère plus le kosovo comme un
état à part entière on peut penser à des
grands pays musulmans d'afrique je pense
six pays de l'union européenne et donc
c'est dans ce contexte très très
difficile et puis vous l'avez dit
troisième point c'est une situation
économique déplorable qu'aux c'est le
trou noir de l'europe
c'est vraiment la région au taux de
chômage les plus importants en europe et
ce qui explique aussi le la fuite
massive d'une grande part
isabelle et les peaux sont donc dans ce
contexte on a comme vous dites cette
opposition politique entre les anciens
membres de checa et comme vous l'avez
très bien présente et qui vont être
qu'ils ne sont plus tous soutenus par la
population et ce jeune albine corti qui
veut absolument redonner plus de force à
l'autodétermination du kosovo quels sont
les dossiers prioritaires pour le futur
gouvernement a notamment pour une
cantine que vous venez de mentionner
s'il venait à prendre la tête du
gouvernement on entend souvent parler
des relations tendues avec la serbie
voisine on le rappelle un le kosovo
comme vous l'avez dit n'est pas reconnu
par 95 pays l'onu ne reconnaît pas le
kosovo la russie l'union européenne la
chine ne reconnaissent pas ce territoire
exactement ce jeunes indépendantistes et
nationalistes alors certes de gauche là
il va énormément de dossiers sociaux à
régler mais jusqu'au dernier jour c'est
à dire jusqu'à hier il a très bien dit
que les négociations sous l'égide de
l'onu et des grandes puissances
entreprise avec belgrade depuis 2013 ces
négociations il le il fera tout pour les
mener à l'avantagé du kosovo ça veut
dire quoi concrètement
pendant que belgrade et seysses escrime
depuis des mois voire des années à avoir
des relations normales on appelle ça
d'ailleurs des discussions de
normalisation tous les gouvernements
successifs au kosovo ont refusé donc moi
je pense que c'est dans ce cadre là que
ce jeune dirigeant a aussi poursuivre la
politique d'aidé abanico c'est à dire
essayer de jouer la ligne nationaliste
et s'appuyer sur leur grand allié
américain
sauf qu'ils n'ont pas compris vous
parlez du grand allié américain
mais en quoi le kosovo est il si
stratégique au niveau géopolitique vous
qui êtes géopolitologue
on le rappelle les etats unis
soutiennent le kosovo vous venez de le
dire pourquoi on se rappelle d'ailleurs
vous avez eu un sur notre antenne l'été
dernier on se rappelle d'une image assez
spectaculaire dans le bureau ovale la
maison blanche autour de donald trump
qui vit il y avait le président serbe
aleksandar vucic un peu surpris par ce
qui se passait et puis en face de lui à
côté il y avait également le
représentant kosovar hashim thaçi dans
l'écho volée mais le kosovo n'est pas
reconnue par les eaux
le mans n'est pas reconnue punk en
puissance parce que tout le monde sait
très bien que ça serait un précédent
historique dans une région qui n'a pas
de passé historique qui serait reconnu
par une minorité de murs des pays
devenus et donc qui amènerait des des
conséquences terribles dans la région
pourquoi les américains à ce séparatisme
comme a dit noam chomsky c'est toujours
la théorie du chaos que trump et ses
successeurs vont continuer je rappelle
que joe biden est un était vraiment à d
et si vous voulez à la tête depuis plus
de 20 ans du lobby albanais aux états
unis et donc moi j'ai très peur peut les
etats-unis accentuent ce sont des
pratiques ce pourquoi être pour tout
simplement ils ont leurs principales
bases qui s'appelle bondsteel du monde
un militaire américain tué au vietnam
mais durand galindo bon style qui est là
au kosovo au coeur de l'europe
plus de 8000 hommes ils sont en
permanence et pour très longtemps
c'est la principale base militaire de
redéploiement des armées américaines
extérieur et puis deuxième fait le
kosovo regorge de richesses du sous-sol
alors du lignite du zinc con mais aussi
de tous ces nouveaux matériaux
militaires
et si vous voulez c'est au regard de ses
richesses peut se joue là encore ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque le grand jeu
c'est une opposition entre les
américains qui soutiennent finalement
qu'aux et ses dirigeants kosovars qui
n'ont que des yeux du maine pour le
grand frère américain est en face les
autres pays et passons à serbie mais
serbie macédoine
maintenant une partie avec dusty et le
monténégro depuis quelques mois qui eux
de plus en plus se tourner vers la
russie
et donc c'est le principal danger
actuellement c'est-à-dire à nouveau la
guerre froide un européen beaucoup
d'enjeux donc politiques et
géopolitiques autour de ces élections
législatives anticipées à pristina merci
beaucoup alexis troupe d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur en
histoire et en jouant et en géopolitique
spécialiste des balkans